ja ich muss leider auch eine bitterböse
diese anbringen und zwar habe ihn vor
allem der letzten woche das gibt nicht
bekommen dass deutschen medien vor allem
eines ein und das ist ihre freiheits
verachtung es ging so schlimm aber wenn
man seit die kronen zahlen steigen kann
man irgendwie beitrage zählen also
beiträge in zeitungen und auch sonst von
verfassungsrechtlern oder soziologen
aber eben auch redaktoren in den
zeitungen wieder fahrt solle das mit
deutschland oder zeit die irgendwie dem
individuum die schuld quasi in allem die
man das ende des zeitalters des
individuums heran schreiben das ich muss
quasi in das kollektiv zurücktreten für
das allgemeinwohl das nimmt mir doch
einigermaßen wunder beziehungsweise auch
wieder ein bisschen nicht weil die
deutschen sind schon ein sehr
kultiviertes
ticken das volk gefragt - das jemals
ändern soll weil wenn irgendwie die den
meinungs- diskurs bestimmen die dem
einzelnen die eigenverantwortung
absprechen dann kann sie das ja auch nie
ändern aber freiheit beginnt ja nun mal
beim einzelnen und nicht bei der gruppe
also eine gesellschaft besteht auch nur
als individuen weil das individuum
genäht ist das handelt das frei ist und
das denkt also insofern es gibt keinen
kollektiven gedanken es gibt kein heute
diskutieren und er wird mir sehr
wünschen dass diese session des
individualismus ein ende findet das sind
ein ganz gutes thema weil ich auch
gestolpert in dieser woche über den chef
des weltverbandes frank ulrich
montgomery
und das ist dessen schlagwort vom
freiheits häusel das fand ich das wäre
für mich eigentlich das unwort des
jahres das klingt irgendwie so als ob
freiheit so eine lästige geschichte ist
muss doch jeder einsehen ist jetzt ein
bisschen hinterlassen weil das jetzt mal
mit der freiheit und beim nächsten
lernen können was auch wieder machen so
ähnlich höre ich das manchmal von frei
bis fünf user weil die dringlichkeit des
klimaschutzes ist ja unwidersprochen
also jetzt gehört auch mit eurem
demokratischen mechanismen das dauert
alles zu lange wir müssen jetzt erstmal
handeln und wenn man erstmal so rangeht
dass man sagt die
grundfesten dieser freiheitlichen
ordnung sind eigentlich je nach anlass
verhandelbar und wenn sie jetzt gerade
nicht passt dann nächste woche wieder
mal gucken ob st aber dann besser ist
das ist so interessant seltsame
grundhaltung um jetzt nicht zu schwer zu
werden böckenförde hat ja mal gesagt der
gemeine verfassungsrichter wir leben von
grundlagen in dieser ordnung die wir
selbst nicht schaffen können da ist
natürlich was dran und diese wurstigkeit
wie man mit den grundrechten umgeht die
macht mir auch durchaus sorgen weil am
ende
sich möglicherweise sogar mehrheiten
dafür finden dass man sagt ja sehen wir
alle notlage können wir nächste woche
reden wir wieder darüber finde ich
schwierig ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt
warum wir gerade auch im osten
deutschlands eine große große abneigung
sehen gegen diese maßnahmen weil da dass
sich viele millionen menschen leben die
für die freiheit gestritten gekämpft
haben sich eingesetzt haben und damit
auch etwas bewirkt haben auch und dass
die jetzt
empfindungen haben zu recht auch zu
sagen ich will nicht gegängelt werden in
einrichtungen die ich vielleicht nicht
rein will muss man absolut
nachvollziehen und verstehen auch aber
nochmal die situation die wir jetzt
haben nicht daran dass die ungeimpften
unsolidarisch sind mit dem rest der
gesellschaft den freiheit ist und man
aus münchen hält sich so zitieren auch
immer die freiheit der andersdenkenden
und ich muss nicht das kollektiv im
blick behalten aber trotzdem das
gemeinwohl und wenn durch mein verhalten
viele menschen hospitalisiert werden
durch mein ungeimpfte essverhalten und
viele menschen eben in die
intensivstationen müssen im endeffekt
oder ich selber gar und das
gesundheitssystem damit belastet da muss
man schon die frage stellen ist dass der
freiheitsbegriff den wir haben und leben
wollen oder gefährdet dieser
freiheitsbegriff als totale ego
bezogenheit nicht den rest der
gemeinschaft dieser unterschied ist in
diesen 30 eben nicht das totale egon
sondern von dem machen was sie will uns
egal wie und ein schaden im gegenteil
aber die ist ja es ist nichts also
worauf ich hinaus will ist das die
letzte woche wenn es zu beobachten was
dazu geschrieben wurde das egal wer sagt
aber denkt auch noch jemanden die
freiheit das wenn ich sage die freiheit
muss sie rechtfertigen ihre
beschränkungen aber immer und dann kommt
zurück oh gott das ist dieser dieser
radikal individualismus und das geht ja
so nicht also dass alleine das
aussprechen dieser einfachen wahrheit
geht schon gar nimmer und man muss dass
das schon zurückstecken es bestreitet
niemand dass im pandemie irgendwie
beschränkungen gelten müssen
sie tragen eine maske das ist alles fake
net vor irgend jemanden zu schaden aber
das alleine wenn ich sagt können
vielleicht ruhe nachdenken wie schwierig
das ist eigentlich und dass das nicht
normal ist und dass der ernsthaft quert
auch die deutschen medien geschrieben
wird hört auf mit diesem radikalen
individualismus da ja nur egoismus ist
das finde ich
muss sagen ich finde das ganze ist
einfach so völlig in deutsche
die neat und tradition also ich jetzt
eine spezialität der korona politik also
dass man jetzt nicht speziell freiheits
auffiel ist in deutschland das ist doch
irgendwie schon längstens bekommt also
hier ist einfach so dass wir gegen
anderen irgendwie leid aber hier ist
doch einfach das große thema immer
gleichheit und gerechtigkeit und dabei
ist darauf geschaut dass es so ist und
irgendwie also als ich noch in berlin
gewohnt habe irgendwie vor einem jahr
dachte ich ja nicht immer die deutschen
könnte man eigentlich zehn jahren lockt
der anschicken und keine ordnung würden
sich vielleicht ein paar zählen zählen
in sachsen wurden oder im büro zu hause
bleiben das kann sagen das ist wirklich
schlimmer geworden als beispiel ich
wurde gestern auf twitter sehr hart
angegangen ist meine aussagen für cupid
tote schuld wären und er habe ich lange
überlegt jetzt bei uns von grünen
bundestagsabgeordneten also jetzt nicht
irgendwie weiß ich habe erst gedacht
dass werden internet treu bis ich dann
gesehen habe ist ja doch keiner und ich
frage mich wirklich ist kann immer
dieser begriff solidarität
ich muss sagen und du weißt ja dass ich
gebe ich bin weder das sage ich jetzt
auch immer dann auch bloß keiner denkt
ich wäre jemand der nicht geben dass ich
bin gegeben aber wenn ich höre diese
wollte egoismus die sind schuld da muss
ich sagen und du weißt wie gerne ich
dich mag aber der regen sich mir so
richtig so wird mir ganz schlecht beim
ich finde solidarität bedeutet doch auch
solidarisch mit den zu sein die gerade
vielleicht das gefühl haben dass in die
gesellschaft zu viel abverlangt
vielleicht wird irgendwann die
gesellschaft mal die er in irgendwo zu
viel abverlangen wir sagen das bin ich
nicht bereit zu geben wie die jetzt
gerade nicht bereit sind die impfung
machen zu lernen
ist auch keine fertiggerichte sofern 2
und es ist ja nicht so dass ich das
grundrecht auf freiheit ablehnen ganz im
gegenteil nur wie ist die lage ein
ganzes volk geht jetzt so wie vielten
zum vierten mal in loket wahrscheinlich
wir haben die lage unsere wirtschaft
leidet die weihnachtsmärkte werden
abgesagt ich meine das muss man ja auch
mal vorstellen das sind leute die haben
nahrung eingekauft haben und und und und
leute eingestellt dafür die sind alle
jetzt quasi vor dem briten so ist ja und
und flächendeckend fast schon bald
andere weihnachtsmärkte neben münchen
werden sicherlich auch abgesagt werden
also insofern hat es da auch erhebliche
wirtschaftspolitische und wirtschafts
auswirkungen du bist jemand der sich
sehr für wirtschaft interessiert und
sich daraus geht also das muss man ja
nachvollziehen können auch das heißt es
großteils eingelegt weihnachtsmärkten
doch die ungeimpften tragen zum
wesentlichen dazu bei dass diese
infektionszahlen gibt in zwei drittel
derjenigen die auf den intensivstationen
liegen sind ungeimpfte und das sind
nicht geimpfte also muss man doch den
zusammenhang suchen und bei diese
intensivstation voll laufen das ist der
bewertungsmaßstab der neue deswegen
haben wir diesen locker und der bald
kommt und deswegen haben wir diese
verschärften was aber es geht doch auch
um strategisches verhalten der politik
will man die bürger für die politik
gewinnen oder nicht wenn man sie nicht
gewinnen will sagt man ihm vor wie die
roten oder irgendwie bekommen hat
offenbar begonnen wie das hat man eben
schon sehr früh auf angefangen hatte ich
den eindruck in deutschland man hat die
leute eben schon vermutlich viel zu früh
aufgegeben und jetzt ist es tatsächlich
vermutlich zu spät aber vielleicht auch
mal sagen freiheit ist das recht aus der
reihe tanzen zu dürfen und wenn über 70
prozent geimpft sind dann ist das für
eine freiheitliche ordnung egal in
welchem kontext ein riesen mehrheit das
gibt es bei keinem wahlen das gibt es
bei den wenigsten volksabstimmungen dass
eine nation so geschlossen zu mehr als
zwei dritteln hinter einem thema steht
wenn man jetzt sagen nordkoreanische
mehrheitsverhältnisse weil die lage es
gerade erfordert ein ford dann
überfordert man einfach unser
grundsystem so dass sich sowieso sind
wir nicht geschafft wenn man dann auch
gehalten sollten sich impfen lassen das
mit nordkorea gleich zu setzen das ist
natürlich anders diese nicht absehbar
dass das problem eben weil was wäre die
lösung also urlaub gegeben bin ich
felsenfest von ihm als projekt ich würde
es geben aufgrund der tatsache dass
viele sagen ich lasse mich nicht impfen
nicht bereit dazu sind und wie diese
zustände haben wie wir sie haben und ich
will nicht noch eine fünfte welle haben
ich glaube dass er das der blick ein
falscher ist zu sagen dass die
ungeimpften also eine wirklich kleine
gruppe dass die schuld an dem ganzen
sind wir haben außerdem außer acht
gelassen dass auch geimpfte weitertragen
wir haben außer acht gelassen dass
kinder beispielsweise auch den das virus
tragen und verbreiten können und das
trifft dann welche also dass das
geschehen ist aus meiner sicht komplexer
als dass man sich jetzt auf eine doch
sehr kleine gesellschaft die gruppe 1
schoss